aquí te muestro las herramientas que te
recomiendo tener para la construcción de
un robot primero lentes de seguridad
siempre ten los puestos punteros durante
todo el proceso de la construcción de tu
robot pues te protegerán de cosas que
puedan saltar o salir volando también
vas a necesitar un cautín y su soporte
asegúrate de siempre poner el cautín en
su soporte cuando no lo estés usando y
también recuerda de desconectar el
cautín el cautín te servirá para
derretir la soldadura y hacer conexiones
este es un pegador de cables te
permitirá pelar el aislamiento de los
cables entonces tú tomas el cable así y
le cortas el aislamiento eso te
permitirá hacer una mejor conexión
también asegúrate de que tu pelador de
cables pueda pelar cables de calibre 22
luego tenemos nuestras pinzas de punta
estas te permiten doblar el cable
formando un tipo de gancho con el cual
tú puedes conectar el cable con otras
cosas también tenemos pinzas para cortar
con estas tú puedes cortar el cable
o con las pinzas de punta plana tú
puedes doblar el cable o también
engancharlo entonces bueno para eso
sirven las pinzas y también tenemos el
desarmador el cual podrás usar para
formar agujeros en las tapas de botellas
y por supuesto también tenemos la
pistola de silicón caliente que nos
permite derretir el silicón y así poder
pegar partes